hey guys how's it going so I thought
today that I would make something
absolutely foolproof granted I am a fool
but I think that if I mess this up I
don't deserve to eat ever again today
we're gonna make rice krispies treats
we've already started out with things a
little bit on the rocky side cuz Jenna
was at the grocery store and I told her
to get any marshmallows that she brought
back marshmallow cream which is totally
fine because in the directions that says
we can use them but I've never made rice
krispies treats this way before so this
is gonna be all new to me
I think I might I'm not sure six cups of
this I'm gonna need a big bowl three
tablespoons of butter like I thought
that much one package of jet Puft
Marshmallow this this is great this is
working out well get out of there what
this tastes like there's like
marshmallow it is marshmallow it's
marshmallow
well marshmallow cream and a
microwave-safe bowl heat the butter
marshmallows on high for 30 minutes
stirring after two minutes three minutes
on the clock
what are you doing I decided I'm going
to use this pan because it's all I can
find
so it looks like things are happening in
there I'm a little concerned about it
stirring after two minutes it's been a
little less than two minutes but I think
that this needs to be stirred god this
smells like I'm sure it's quite a nice
scent
something extra to this baby like some
sprinkles that sprinkles
little sprinkle balls I don't have a
spatula put in the sprinkles all of the
sprinkles oh this looks like garbage
okay let's go so we need 12 of these yep
oh man it's chocolate and it's melting
oh it's four cups okay good yes
last one dad this looks good shake shake
why are you mourning well because the
other one's all melted so now there's no
more sprinkles mm-hmm this is good they
said to use a wax paper to press it down
now put some more these on top all right
guys check it out this is what I would
like to call success I would put this in
the fridge and we'll cut it up later
after it cools be right back all right
everybody here is the big finale the
crispys I think they're gonna look
really good an interesting color to the
Krispies well that would be the melted
sprinkles is it hard yeah
oh wait this is the top I hope you look
good I love me too that's right it's
good and a little crunchy from there you
want sprinkles mmm this is a great taste
good wow thank you guys so much for
watching this is what success looks like
I'll see you guys in the next video
leave me some comments below let me know
what you would like me to cook next
goodbye Germany Dresden it's been fun
we're off to Rome